foreign
the public health policy the doctors who
are making the policy and her who are
actually interacting with patients
mostly don't know how to think
evolutionarily yep and that that that is
the core problem and so just one example
that that we have been talking about for
a long time is that most people
including most doctors but including
perhaps especially the many of the
intellectuals and so-called
intellectuals out there including those
with medical and scientific training
actually make claims like why does it
matter where Cyrus Kobe 2 came from like
it what could it possibly matter it's
irrelevant to how we respond to it right
like we were hearing this back in 2020
and we're continuing to hear it now it's
ridiculous and I went back and I think
that the first time but it may not have
been the first time that we specifically
talked about this we've talked about it
over and over and over again why does
the origin of the virus matter in terms
of how the virus will then act in humans
continue to evolve and what and and
therefore should be used to inform how
we actually act at a public health level
on July 14 2020 on Dark Horse live
stream number 30 at time stamp 30
minutes and 39 seconds and I'll put this
into the show notes you start discussing
why and how a lab origin may explain why
the virus acts the way it does with
regard to effect on children and
transmission outdoors and other things
so that's in July of 2020 and I'm not
sure that was the first time you were
talking about it or we were talking
about it but I know that at least it
happened at least that far at least then
and we've been talking about it ever
since and using an evolutionary
understanding of okay if not zoonotic
because from almost the very beginning
it's the evidence is pointed not
zoonotic but lab origin what else can we
say about what is going to happen next
that is part of what we have been doing
that is part of the model that we have
been using which guess what was
available to anyone who wanted it
and and you know this is part of why I
you know I agree with you this doesn't
look like an error because you know this
it doesn't cost money
um it takes some practice and it takes
some patience and it takes being willing
to be wrong and to rethink you know when
you arrive at some place that is wrong
and go back to the last place on which
you are certain that you're on firm
intellectual ground and go okay well
let's take the other Branch then like
you have to be doing that all the time
and most people feel like oh it's not
what I do I don't have time that makes
me look weak something
um but you we need it like we need all
the people who are making decisions on
behalf of any of the rest of us to
absolutely 100 be willing to have
exactly what the author of this piece
calls epistemic humility but like actual
epistemic humility not the kind uh that
he is asking for the kind that he needs
to and that all of these people need and
the and that we have like that we need
and we and you need to constantly check
in with yourself be like
help you know am I wrong how would I
know who can I ask what can I check with
in terms of you know how many of the
views that I hold are inconsistent and
do it all the time that's the thing it
doesn't end you don't get to like do
this and be like okay I did I graduated
I'm done thinking for myself now now I'm
an expert now now I'm an expert and what
I believed on that day of graduation is
always true shall always be true nothing
ever shall change because my degree says
so like that's not how the world Works
no and and uh if I might this epistemic
humility thing is going to become very
important and I'm I'm concerned that
this abuse of it it's like
evidence-based medicine like who
wouldn't be in favor of evidence-based
medicine until you dig and you discover
that evidence-based medicine doesn't
mean evidence-based medicine right right
um so anyway the point is epistemic
humility involves building a circuit in
which you are very sensitive to evidence
that you have something important wrong
and you are highly motivated to face it
down so that as quickly as possible you
can fix the error and stop being wrong
exactly right and so does that process
end absolutely not right what you do is
you get closer and closer to right which
means you get closer and closer to a
model that is more and more predictive
while assuming less that's the whole
point of the exercise and anybody who
thinks that they've got this wired and
now they need to tell doctors to sit
down right is not displaying epistemic
humility they're displaying the opposite
they're displaying a kind of arrogance
which they would like to of course cloak
in the idea of humility because it's
very attractive to do that but it's not
right it's it is you are putting us in
danger for the next one exactly and I
mean I'm reminded I mean this is
this is a theme this is a drum beat of
ours but um this piece that I wrote
you know what if we're wrong
uh it was first published in area and
then I republished it on my on my sub
stack specifically goes goes after
um the certainty
that so many people seem to have and you
know ironically it is our supposed
certainty that people attack us for and
it is their certainty of things that
we've said that we never said that is
the basis for a lot of these you know
freezy beliefs and accusations and
frankly at different levels in different
places policies that are being that are
being implemented so
why are
doctors it's one thing to say okay most
people don't understand how to think
evolutionarily uh it's not necessarily
widespread in high school or college
curricula even you know even if you're a
biology major maybe you had you know a
course maybe right so still though it
seems like doctors you know if if
if we're right and if Nessie and
Williams are right and why we get sick
and everything about us is the product
and products of evolution
obviously doctors should be trained in
practiced in skilled in understanding
how to think evolutionarily
so I did a little
search on medical school curricula in
the U.S and I just pulled up five first
I first I Googled and the first one that
came up was uh Drexel University's
College of Medicine and then I went you
know what I'm going to actually just
pick four more not randomly but out of
my head so I went and looked at Stanford
University of Florida and Gainesville
Harvard Drexel and the University of
Washington
um here in Washington state in Seattle
and uh searched and I don't have clear
visuals so I'm just going to walk us
through this I basically looked for the
curriculum that is required for all
medical students and to the degree that
it was available tried to search on all
of the courses offered but
specifically searched on not just the
names of courses but the course
descriptions for all of when it was
available first second third fourth year
coursework and all the required
coursework and I searched on the word
Evolution and then I also searched on
just the just Evo because evolutionarily
evolutionary right could show up
at Stanford there are many different
Pathways possible every med student
takes the same course as the first year
they do have a social justice and Health
Equity curriculum which is prominently
displayed but the word Evolution even
the road the the root EVO shows up
zero times at Stanford
University of Florida College of
Medicine the required courses Year One
no Evolution you're two
no Evolution year three and four nope
none never
okay Harvard Medical School core courses
no mention and again I'm not just
looking at titles of courses I'm looking
at course descriptions I'm searching on
course descriptions here
nothing
The Drexel College of Medicine
nope how about the University of
Washington School of Medicine
um no they make it a little bit harder
to assess because they've got all these
different Pathways but uh but no none of
the pages I landed on could I find a
single there was one page on one of
these sites where Evo showed up
but it was within the word developing so
that doesn't count
right right uh so literally five and
this is some of the top medical schools
in the country and some that aren't
um five medical schools in the US right
now with regard to their required and to
some degree as much as I was able to
find it they're not required but if
you're interested in this that or the
other curriculum
make no mention of evolution anywhere in
the coursework and that's not to say of
course that some of these classes once
you're in it might occasionally
reference Evolution I assume that they
do but it's that referencing which is to
say of course we all know that and
therefore we all understand that we are
evolved but frankly most people who
think they believe in evolution don't
have any idea what they're doing they
don't know how it works they don't know
how to think evolutionarily and it's how
you get to
people imagining that clinical work was
going on here with with covet it wasn't
this was this was not in any way
informed by what we actually are as
evolved human beings this whole three
years none of it it flew in the face
yeah and that is in some sense the story
of what we did is we just constantly
checked reality against
uh an evolutionary model and what was
being advised never made any sense which
alarmed us to a greater and greater
degree yes
um I did want to point out you you it
may or may not be easy for you to find
but that sentence that you said was a
cryptic reference to Adaptive Landscapes
oh yeah it's relevant here if you can
find it I think I can
uh this was in page 236 here we go um
it's like the last sentence in what
you're almost there was the previous
paragraph but
um
if the organism has two if the organism
had been designed with the possibility
of fresh start some major changes there
would be better ways of preventing many
diseases alas every successive
generation of the human body must
function well with no chance to go back
and start afresh perfect is that it yeah
now here's the reason I want to
resurrect that again as with the Thomas
Soul quote that happens to apply to
biology or vice versa
um
the quote you've just read There is a
reference to what you and I would
technically call historical contingency
and an engineer might call Path
dependence okay
now I want to point out that the and by
the way it's not just that five medical
schools make no mention of it it's five
of five that you looked at exactly it's
like I I could have kept going you could
have kept going what happened like I
would love I would love to have anyone
who's who says you know actually this
medical school is the exception yeah it
would be great to know if it exists I've
been saying for I don't know how long
decades that
um that medicine is still taught as if
Darwin had never published yes
um exactly and so anyway why is that now
I want to give them their due I want to
explain where that initially came from
because it did have a good reason at
first
and then it no longer has a good reason
and we are now paying a tremendous price
the non-evolutionary nature of medicine
okay
the problem is
um you
discover a powerful principle like
natural selection you know 1859 Darwin
finally publishes what he's been working
on the world is suddenly aware of
something it can be sort of summed up in
a paragraph but it's really not clear
what it implies about medicine if you
were to say aha suddenly we know what we
are surely that impacts medicine let's
go back and revise the curriculum you
know three weeks after Darwin published
you would be more likely to do harm than
good yeah right because there wasn't
enough understanding of what the
implications what Darwin had said was
too crude you don't add the new stuff to
the Core Curriculum right away right so
my point is initially there is a reason
for doctors not to jump at Evolution
even though in a philosophical sense it
was obvious that it would ultimately
have tremendous implications and that
frankly medicine should start with
selection right every medical curriculum
on Earth should start with this because
it is riddled throughout it whether you
mention it or not whether you understand
it or not right clonal selection the the
way in which a vaccine induces immunity
is a sped up version of literal genetic
Evolution inside the body right if you
don't understand the nuances of how
selection works then you're not going to
understand clonal selection and you're
going to just see vaccination as a kind
of a black box that induces something
important that fends off disease and
you're going to screw up when they try
to feed you something that doesn't work
this way or doesn't properly work this
way or they have to use an adjuvant
because what they gave you isn't good
enough to induce the response or any of
these things so anyway at first
there is a reason for doctors not to
jump at Darwinism but then it becomes a
territorial question and they get used
to not thinking evolutionarily even as
evolutionary thinking catches up and
then overtakes medicine with its
capacity to say something about what is
likely to do more harm than good right
so we are still dealing with a several
thousand year old oath to do no harm but
the principle that would allow you to
see where harm is before you do it is
not invoked in any core way in medical
curricula which is frightening at this
point right that historical contingency
is resulting Us in us not going back and
saying well
is 2023
maybe it's time to rewrite the medical
curriculum in light of all of the things
that we have now learned about the way
Evolution works right it wasn't ready in
1859 in 2023 it's long overdue and it's
not like the field of evolutionary
medicine hasn't progressed since the
publishing of that book but what it has
been done is it what has been done is it
been segregated the point is it is
treated as non-medical the same way
evolutionary psychology is treated
outside of the clinical practice right
the point is it's an abstraction oh it's
very nice that we can think in a
darwinian way about medicine no it's not
very nice it's fundamentally important
when you go into your doctor's office in
fact it's not an add-on it's not an
add-on and I believe that book has a
terrible piece of advice uh from Richard
Dawkins on the back uh
does it say something about uh buy two
copies and give one to your doctor buy
two copies and give one to your doctor I
know this is terrible advice because I
did it
I can imagine how that went over oh so
okay I don't know what to ask well I
mean basically the point is it is taken
as an affront it is taken as a challenge
to somebody's expertise rather than a
hey you and I are in parallel Fields I'm
not in no position to to tell you about
medicine but I am in a position to tell
you about something that I know isn't
included in that medicine and this might
change your thinking right so anyway
um your doctor wasn't appreciative no my
doctor was not appreciative which I get
right but nonetheless my doctor well I
don't know if my doctor went on to read
it or not but my doctor assuming that
his initial reaction was indicative
he didn't throw it he just looked at me
like I had walked in from Mars
um
but in any case
path dependence that is a feature of a
Model A model of developing systems
medicine is a developing system the
human body is a developing system it's
not surprising the path dependence ends
up a relevant piece of uh to the toolkit
for understanding both things and
medicine is in the process of screwing
up by not being evolutionary which is a
big part of as you point out why you and
I with no budget sitting here just
hashing stuff out in front of a camera
we're able to beat all of these experts
because we have a model that was
actually relevant across the pandemic
evolution is relevant across the
pandemic it's relevant to the evolution
of the pathogen it is relevant to the
evolution of the immune response it is
relevant to the human body and the
Damage that is done to it by both
pathogens and by badly formulated
Pharmaceuticals the point is
it's not just another field it is a
baseline toolkit that works for any of
these complex systems that have this
adaptive feature at their core
and it should be updating medicine which
it is not doing
it's really really not
[Music]
foreign